because I'm a woman they hate the fact
that I'm a woman in crypto winning and
so anything I do they hypersexualize me
they laugh at me they call me stupid
Kevin I made $100,000 in less than a
week on an eth trade and they still
think that I'm an idiot because I'm a
woman I saw an account today and all
they did they create these memes of me
with like boobs spilling over and all of
that that's not how I present myself I
saw a major male accounts say that the
Bitcoin spot ETF was not a buy the rumor
sell the news event these men they said
that the market was going to pump they
said that anybody saying that the
Bitcoin sport ETF was buy the rumor sell
the news event is stupid they don't know
what they're talking about these are men
nobody came running after them they come
running after me but it's absolutely
fine because I made $100,000 in less
than a week